hello all you vagrants and vagaries
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 57 you know
we have to put this Tuesday thing to bed
because you guys always comment but you
don't release on a Tuesday what's the
deal with that the truth is I don't film
on a Tuesday I don't write on a Tuesday
sometimes I add it on Tuesday and I most
usually don't release on a Tuesday
either it's just sort of become this
running joke I mean I sometimes think
you know it's Tuesday somewhere but then
I realize that does make any sense and
then I think I just like the way it
sounds REM koolhaas in his famous
delirious New York writes the metropolis
strives to reach a mythical point where
the world is completely fabricated by
man so that it absolutely coincides with
his desires REM you're right it's true
here all geometries are achingly formal
even the parks and public gardens fit
snugly into the parallelograms that the
streets and avenues draw anything you
want you can have the metropolis is made
for consumption leisure ease of travel
it complements and encourages that
profound pulp fiction novel truth which
is that after 1920 the whole world
became about Saturday night getting sex
in this round each player has only one
minute to retrieve a woman's phone
number let's see how our players perform
a speed deduction one of the
inevitabilities about this city and all
cities I suspect is that as you consume
it it consumes you and it fills you up
with its own self to the exclusion of
all else Manhattan is the perfect
metaphor for itself because it's
literally an island and if it all of a
sudden broke off and floated out into
the Atlantic it's unclear how many of us
would really mind of course we'd have to
take Brooklyn in tow cities are designed
in a very insular way to obscure the
world outside their walls from the
ground you can only see a few blocks in
every direction and the city just
recedes into more city its residents in
this way worship the present moment in
salvos of anxiety and pleasure and in
that worship and within these geometric
towers there is no anchor to the outside
world no frame of reference
since time spins out of control like how
in the lack of properly defined seasons
Los Angeles skips from year to year
without remark and in the absence of
structure a relativism takes hold a
feeling of anomie sits heavily on the
soul an owe me the lack of social or
ethical standards in an individual or
group as God dies and the great cities
are born a know me is the keynote of the
world and we wait for the harvest of a
godless relativistic morality last
Friday was the full moon I came out of
the subway and was transfixed as
transfixed as if I had seen an intruder
in my home it hung there brightly
indifferently shining and observing the
comings and goings of all the harried
city dwellers as the culture around them
decayed and advanced at just the same
rate I was reminded of the night a
stavos brief sojourn to the moon in
ariados famous Orlando Furioso where
searching for a cure to Orlando's
madness the night comes upon that valley
where all lost things on earth are found
deep in a veil conducted by his guide
where Rose a mountain steep on either
side he came and saw a wonder to relate
whatever was wasted in our earthly state
here safely treasured each neglected
good time squandered or occasion ill
bestowed not only here our wealth and
scepters found that ever-changing shift
the unsteady round but those possessions
while on earth we live which fortunes
hand can neither take nor give much fame
is there which here the creeping hours
consume till time at length the whole
devours their vows and their unnumbered
prayers remain which off to God the
sinner makes in vain the frequent tears
that lovers eyes fuse the sighs they
breathe the days that gamesters lose the
leisure given which fools so often
neglect the weak designs that never take
effect whatever designs the mortal
breasts assail in countless numbers fill
the uncovered veil for whatever is lost
by humankind ascending here you
treasured safe may find and then I
wondered if a Stouffer saw the
lost tenets of common law or under some
garland chance to find the sea cast
fragments of unquiet Minds discarded
like flatteries proffered toward that
bone-white kingdom without a lord as a
fool to a stranger's care consigns his
own children and for most rhymes would
the night pleased with Orlando's vile on
his chariot span the starlit Isle and
bring to those who cast off and forgot
the essence of this urban thought